after the emotionally draining epic that
was avengers endgame
spider-man far from home swung into
theaters to offer some sweet relief to
the legions of Marvel fans looking for a
superhero fix with slightly smaller
stakes far from home delivered all the
heart thrills and goofiness we've come
to expect since Tom Holland took over
the spandex in 2016 s Captain America
Civil War but there are a lot of little
touches and far from home you probably
missed a mighty earth elemental wreak
some serious havoc in Mexico during the
cold opening of far from home so we
don't blame you if you didn't catch the
super nerdy clue the filmmakers briefly
put on screen to herald its arrival a
license plate with only four six three
visible appears briefly near Nick Fury
and Maria hill when the elemental pops
up this is likely a nod to amazing
spider-man number four from September
1963 the issue that introduced the world
to the earth-based villain Sandman sound
like a stretch while Marvel already
snuck a few license plate based Easter
eggs into the far from home trailers
that didn't make the theatrical cut of
the film before the water elemental
attack is teased in the first official
teaser trailer from January 2019 for
example there was a boat in the
background with a SM to12 on the side
it's almost certainly a reference to
amazing spider-man number 212 the issue
that introduced Spidey's wet bread
hydro-man Flash Thompson even tells his
classmates about a guy who got water
powers named Morris bench that he read
about on the Internet another clear
reference to the comic book alter-ego of
hydro man but that's not all in a
london-based clip scene in the official
trailer from May 20 19 a car with the
license plate to 865 SCP appears this
probably refers to amazing spider-man
number 28 from September 1965 which
marked the debut of fire villain molten
man this particular UK plate was cut
from the final film but a similar plate
number pops up in Prague in the
theatrical cut ASM - eight nine six five
four issue number 28 September 1965
there's also at least one other license
plate based Easter Egg and far from home
that has nothing to do with the
elementals MTU eight 3779 spotted on
nick fury's license plate in berlin it
may look like just another random string
of letters and numbers but we're
guessing it's a reference to Marvel
team-up number 83 from July 1979 which
featured a team-up
between spider-man and Fury the story of
MTU number 83 begins or so the text
tells us with a murdered spider-man on a
Manhattan rooftop but wait he awakens
and begins to remember the events of the
night before which culminated in Nick
Fury shooting spider-man and a woman who
appeared to be Black Widow with an
anaesthetic bullet in other words he
used two non-lethal ammo that appeared
real so like in the events of the
Berlin's sequence of far from home MTU
number 83 features fury seemingly at
odds with our friendly neighborhood
spider-man in far from home
fake Nick Fury is an illusion used to
trick and incapacitate spider-man in MTU
number 83 Nick Fury's fake bullets are
an illusion used to trick and
incapacitate spider-man meets the rest
of the plot of MTU number 83 which
involves silver samurai and the
teleportation ring he obtained from
Saturday Night Live's John Belushi is
probably irrelevant it does however
feature a seemingly dead Black Widow
appearing alive and well in a shield lab
but we're not even touching that one
to test his newfound powers in his 1962
amazing fantasy number 15 debut Peter
Parker takes on a muscle-bound wrestler
named crusher Hogan who promises $100 to
anyone who can stay in the ring with him
for three minutes
our spider-man in the making of course
easily bests Hogan and variations on
this origin story have popped up several
times since
[Applause]
after Antony's homeless support
fundraiser and far from home if you look
closely behind happy you'll see a
crusher Hogan poster with that same $100
offer there's also a ring bell nearby so
it looks like this building is where
crusher made the offer we never got to
see the MC use Peter Parker take crusher
down but this poster is a decent
consolation prize and confirmation that
MCU Spidey likely had a similar origin
story as his comics counterpart Benjamin
Franklin Parker aka orphan peter's
father figure Uncle Ben has yet to
appear in the MCU but his memory looms
large in the original amazing fantasy
number 15 origin story Uncle Ben is
killed by an unnamed burglar the same
burglar Peter could have apprehended
following a TV appearance had he not
been so caught up in his newfound fame
Peter later tracks the burglar to a
warehouse where he captures him and
leaves him for the police to deal with
Peter realizes in the final panel
famously that with great power there
must also come great responsibility
spider-man homecoming writer John
Francis Daley told Entertainment Weekly
in 2017 that Uncle Ben was almost
referenced directly in the MCU but plans
changed it was when Peter was getting
ready for homecoming and the Wardrobe
Aunt May was getting Peter was all Uncle
Ben's clothes it was a nice moment but
we also knew that it veered away from
his arc if you're going to talk about
someone's death you don't want it to be
a throwaway in far from home it's
revealed that Peter is using Ben's old
luggage but the connection goes
unmentioned on screen if you look
closely the monogram VFP is featured on
the suitcase in the scene where Peter is
packing for his summer vacation blink
and you'll miss it but the giant novelty
check happy hogan carries into the back
room after the homeless support
fundraiser in far from home is signed by
Pepper Potts Potts is listed here as the
co-founder and chair of the stark relief
foundation which probably sounds
familiar if you've rewatched Avengers
age of Ultron recently stark relief
foundation already on the scene
in age of Ultron Tony Stark asks Maria
Hill about the stark Relief Foundation
following the so called
dual of Johannesburg in which a
spellbound Hulk and a Hulk Buster suited
Tony Stark
caused massive collateral damage to
South Africa's largest city the
Foundation's purpose it appears is to
provide aged two populations impacted by
the messy work the Avengers have
historically engaged in in far from home
viewers can assume that pepper has
donated such a large sum to help the
homeless population of Queens recovering
after the blip the brief but welcome
return of Daily Bugle head honcho Jay
jonah Jameson played once again by JK
Simmons is one of the many highlights so
far from home coming during the mid
credit sequence which appears to set up
the next MCU spider-man flick Simmons
played the cantankerous journalists in
Sam Raimi's spider-man trilogy but far
from Holmes incarnation is a little bit
different thrown in the towel abandoned
his sad little masquerade in far from
home Jameson is more unstable than ever
and his desire to smear spider-man is
cranked up to 11 befitting of the times
the Daily Bugle now appears to be an
online conspiracy mongering tabloid news
program clearly styled to resemble the
o'reilly factor or even the MCU version
of Infowars
this darker take on Jameson then out
spider-man as Peter Parker leading
Parker in far from Holmes final line to
echo the final interrupted line of
homecoming uttered by Aunt May when she
discovers Peters secret
[Music]
considering that X Stark Industries
scientist turn Mysterio Lackey William
Gynt Areva preserved Mysterio's
high-tech handiwork for later use
meaning even more crazily realistic
illusions could be on the way and far
from homes follow up having a paranoid
conspiracy monger like Jonah eager to
smear a now outed Peter Parker is a
recipe for disaster
WTF indeed check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about the MCU are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]